between jefferson's ideas and actions
chief justice rehnquist along with
advocates for the prosecution and
defense examined constitutional
political and social issues involving
the author of the declaration of
independence
this mock trial took place in manhattan
and was sponsored by the new york city
bar association it runs a little over
two hours
welcome to all of you to the trial of
thomas jefferson
name is norman greene and i'm the chair
of the committee on lectures in
continuing education at the association
which has sponsored tonight's event
this program represents the
extraordinary work of our planning
subcommittee
and the association staff
they plan the program down to the
smallest detail
but i want to stress this is just not an
issue of planning
this is a program
made by people who dared to dream how
special a program could be
and tonight our reward is seeing all of
you here
and knowing that something unusual is
about to happen
something a little different
something a little old but something
very very current
with that said and keeping to our
schedule let me introduce to you our
president barbara paul robinson who will
introduce the participants and have
other things to say barbara
thank you very much
we are here tonight
to try thomas jefferson can that be
possible
a trial of one of the great icons of
american history
yet all of you are here to do precisely
that
you who have come to serve as the jury
for this extraordinary trial
you the jury
will be asked to participate in a trial
to determine whether
thomas jefferson
was guilty of inconsistencies
when his words are contrasted with his
deeds
a complaint has been lodged and that
will be explained to you
i thought it important to note
that the first count of the complaint
alleges that thomas jefferson was guilty
of attacking the independence of the
judiciary
how very appropriate to try that issue
in the house of this great association
thomas jefferson was born in 1743
so he's just had his 250th birthday
he lived a long life
and he died at the age of 83 on july 4th
1826
the 50th anniversary of our nation
shortly thereafter a little more than
forty years later
this association was formed
and it was formed for the purpose of
fighting corruption in city government
and in the judiciary
we are about to celebrate the 125th
anniversary of that founding
and this association is still fighting
for those original ideals
for justice
for the independence and integrity of
the judiciary
and for those very special ideals of
individual rights and liberties so ably
articulated by jefferson
personally
i have to admit jefferson holds a very
special niche
in my roster of heroes
not only because of the ideals which you
will address tonight in the trial
but because of the breadth and scope of
his enormous talents
and intellect
in our own age of increased
specialization
his versatility
and his wide range of inquiry seems
sheer genius
when he was a young man i'd like to re
recite for you a little description of
him
giving you a little example of this
breadth
and i quote
a gentleman of 32
who could calculate an eclipse
survey an estate
tie an artery
plan an edifice
try a cause
break a horse
dance a minuet and play the violin
and that was definitely not a complete
list
i was surprised to learn that when he
was president he had investigated the
possibilities
of a vaccination against smallpox
and despite the prevailing medical
opinion of the time to the contrary
he successfully carried out the first
mass vaccination in america
this is particularly noteworthy as we
debate today as you know
our present public health policy and
worry about our failures to inoculate
our population as fully as we might
he was so many things i won't bore you
with them but he was a talented
adventure at inventor a horticulturalist
and certainly a man of letters in the
president's office upstairs i have 21
volumes of his papers
and i hope when you leave here tonight
you will look at the wonderful exhibits
downstairs including some wonderful
original editions of important books
which are down on the first floor
you the jury will focus on the charges
and the evidence to be put to you
for this fascinating chance
to judge one of history's greats
i would like you to join me in thanking
norman greene whom you just heard
who is chair of the committee
and those committee members who worked
so hard to make this wonderful evening
possible
mallon cedarquist
eric friedman norman marcus and
particularly richard meniker you've just
been superb i should thank john ferrick
who is not here i'm sorry to say my
predecessor as president
for his interest and support and by the
way this will lead to the creation of a
committee on legal history
and for alan rostin our council and our
wonderful staff who have worked so hard
to get ready for this wonderful event
but
we are here for the trial
it is i think a tribute to the stature
and importance
we all attribute to thomas jefferson and
the ideals he expressed
and to his very special place in history
that we are graced and honored by the
presence of the participants we have
tonight
the presiding judge this evening as you
know
is the leading jurist in the land
the honorable william h rehnquist chief
justice of the supreme court of the
united states
he has spoken and written extensively
about thomas jefferson and his proper
place in history
so we are particularly fortunate to have
him here tonight to help shape this
trial for your final verdict
for the prosecution
we have professor charles ogletree from
the harvard law school
for the defense
we have the solicitor general of the
united states drew s days iii
formerly himself a professor at the yale
law school
they're witnesses
each a distinguished historian
will be
professor james p shenton of the
columbia university
for the prosecution
and professor joyce appleby of ucla for
the defense
donald fletcher deputy clerk of the
united states district court for the
southern district will act as clerk of
the court
before turning this over to the chief
justice
i would like to quote a few words from
thomas jefferson
and ask you to bear these words in mind
when you move ahead to judge him
by today's standards
the sword of law
should never fall
but on those whose guilt is so apparent
as to be pronounced by their friends
as well as foes
thank you and i turn this over to mr
chief justice
[Applause]
thank you very much barbara
a little over 50 years ago on the 200th
anniversary celebration of thomas
jefferson's birth
felix frankfurter gave the principal
speech at the library of congress
it was entitled the permanence of
jefferson in frankfurter's view the
permanence of jefferson resided not in
his specific theories or acts of
government
but in his democratic faith
frankfurter voiced the truism that each
era finds its own meaning from thomas
jefferson and one can readily understand
how americans in 1943
in the midst of world war ii
would draw inspiration from jefferson's
faith in the ultimate value of
individual liberty in a democratic
society
the question posed to you in the
audience tonight you are the jurors is
whether the legacy of thomas jefferson
is significantly diminished
by what one might call hypocrisy
insincere idealism in short
inconsistencies between his word and
deed
professor ogletree appearing for the
complainants has brought a three-count
indictment against thomas jefferson and
his legacy
the gravemen of the indictment alleges
that jefferson's reputation is unduly
inflated
because he practiced insincere idealism
and we will hear
testimony about jefferson's alleged
inconsistencies tonight
the first count charges jefferson with
attacking the independence of the
federal judiciary and never recognizing
the importance of the judicial branch in
our three-part system of government
the second count alleges that jefferson
while extolling the simple life of an
agrarian republic
lived his personal life quite
differently
the final count charges him with
inadequate fidelity to the bill of
rights and in particular
condemns his actions on the subject of
african-american slavery
professor james shenton will appear as
an expert witness for the complainants
in defense of thomas jefferson will be
solicitor general drew days appearing in
his private capacity tonight
professor joyce appleby will testify as
the expert witness in jefferson's
defense
in a few moments i'll outline the
procedures which we will follow but
before i do so i've been asked to set
the historical scene to a certain extent
before we can answer the question before
the house tonight
whether the jeffersonian legacy is
diminished by insincerity or hypocrisy
we must first have some idea what that
legacy is
there's a tendency to group together the
founding fathers of our country george
washington alexander hamilton thomas
jefferson james madison
and to think of them not only as present
on the national stage at the same time
but as statesmen who thought very much
alike
but this latter idea does not withstand
examination they were by no means peas
in a pod it's easier to categorize some
of his contemporaries than it is to
categorize thomas jefferson
george washington is rightly thought of
as the father of his country
our first president
alexander hamilton was the first and
greatest secretary of the treasury
also author of the substantial part of
the federalist papers
james madison was the father of the
constitution and of the bill of rights
and with hamilton and john jay the
author of the federalist papers
no such easy categorization is available
for thomas jefferson as our expert
historians tonight will probably agree
he categorized himself in the famous
epitaph on his tomb at monticello
and the the epitaph says
here was buried thomas jefferson
author of the declaration of american
independence
of the statute of virginia for religious
freedom
and father of the university of virginia
period
a singularly selective epitaph many
would say omitting as it did his two
terms as president of the united states
his management of the louisiana purchase
in his terms as secretary of state vice
president and governor of virginia among
others
but in another sense the epitaph tells
us a great deal about jefferson his
greatness lay not in the various offices
that he held but in something more
abstract and elusive
it is not that jefferson did not hold
numerous offices he did and uh he had
already
fulfilled enough offices to last a
lifetime by the time that george
washington was sworn in as our first
president in april of 1789 here in new
york uh and at that time jefferson
hamilton madison washington were all
federalists because being a federalist
in 1789 mean that you mean that you
supported the ratification of the new
constitution
those who had opposed it were
anti-federalists
but during the administration of
washington and jefferson
the first 12 years of our nation's
history
jefferson and madison drifted apart from
washington and hamilton and their
ultimate break was the beginning of
political parties in this country
hamilton and jefferson disagreed about a
number of things
hamilton thought that the nation should
be governed as he put it by the rich the
able and the well-born
and he thought it was essential to
attract these people as supporters of
the new government
he thought that is between england and
france which seemed to be perpetually at
war with one another england rather than
france should be the natural ally of the
united states
he thought that the country should
encourage manufacturing so that it could
cease its dependence on europe for
manufactured products
jefferson disagreed with hamilton on
every one of these points he believed in
a democracy of small agrarian land
holders artisans and mechanics
and load everything about large cities
he was entirely sympathetic to the first
stage of the french revolution
and he thought that america should join
hands with france and not with england
as an ally
and these disagreements came up during
the first administration of george
washington when they disagreed about the
funding bill
they disagreed about the
constitutionality and the desirability
of chartering a bank in the united the
bank of the united states
finally in 1800 in what historians call
the second american revolution
jefferson and madison in their party
uh
regained the presidency they gained
control of both houses of congress
and uh turned out the federalists who
were never to return again from every
branch except the judiciary
but as some of you may know uh adams was
a john adams was a lame duck president
from november 1800 to uh
march 1801. it wasn't until 1936
that the presidential inauguration
took place on january 20th rather than
on march 4th
so the federalists had four months in
which they were still in control of the
government and one of the things they
did was to
pass what was called the midnight judges
act which was to create a whole new
bunch of federal judges
and uh uh
it had some good things to it but it was
really resented by the democrats and the
reason it was called the midnight judges
act was because it was said that john
adams stayed up until midnight on the
night before jefferson's inauguration
signing the commissions of these new
judges
so jefferson and the when in his
republican party which really is the
ancestor of today's democratic party
when they came in they had a chip on
their shoulder with respect to the
judiciary
and when samuel chase who was a justice
of the supreme court gave a charge to
the grand jury in baltimore in 1803
in which he criticized the
jeffersonian's repeal of the midnight
judges act
jefferson wrote to one of his
lieutenants in the house of
representatives
and said
are we going to let this guy get by
without some sort of action
the result was the house impeached
samuel chase in 1804 he was tried before
the senate in 1805 and he was acquitted
and uh
so that
jefferson really had no love for the
independence of the judiciary
well after jefferson served two terms as
president he retired to monticello in
1809 but one of his greatest
accomplishments was still ahead of him
the founding of the university of
virginia at charlottesville in 1825.
what then is the legacy of this
remarkable yet often inscrutable man
he was not washington's equal as an
administrator
and how the nation would have fared had
he been its first president is surely
debatable
he was not hamilton's equal as a
political economist
hamilton's vision of the nation's
economic future was far more accurate
than jefferson's
he was not madison's equal as a
systematic political philosopher it is
doubtful that jefferson could or would
have carefully developed a political
theory in the way that madison so abele
did in federalist papers number 10 and
51.
jefferson fell short in all these
particulars
but he championed lofty philosophical
ideas which are capable of catching the
public imagination
in a way that no dissertations about the
art of government or about political
economy are capable of doing
he breathed the spirit of individual
liberty
of the right of everyone to religious
liberty freedom of speech freedom of the
press
not only did government derive its
authority from the consent of the
governed but there were some areas that
were simply off limits to it
the french author victor hugo observed
the greater than the tread of mighty
armies is the power of an idea whose
time has come
jefferson's writings and actions
embodied the great liberal themes of his
time
in a way that none of his contemporaries
did and that i submit is his legacy
we'll now proceed with opening
statements professor ogletree will have
10 minutes
followed by general days
after opening statements the prosecution
will present the testimony of professor
shenton
general days will then have the
opportunity to cross-examine
these proceedings will be clocked and 20
minutes will be allowed for direct
examination 10 minutes for cross
following the prosecution's case
the defense case will be presented in a
like manner
each advocate will have 10 minutes to
sum up after which i will charge you the
audience as the jury you will then
render your decision on the merits in a
form of verdict i will put to you at the
time
professor ogletree you may proceed
may it please the court
mr chief justice
general days
ladies and gentlemen of the jury
we hold these truths to be sacred
and undeniable
that all men
are created equal
and independent
that from that equal creation they
derive rights inherent
and inalienable
among which are the preservation of life
and liberty
and the pursuit of happiness
that to secure these ends governments
are instituted among men
deriving their just powers
from the consent
of the governed
good evening my name is charles ogletree
i have the solemn and painful duty
tonight
of bringing three counts
against thomas jefferson
one of the most remarkable
men in the history of our nation
we have but one simple question for this
jury to answer tonight
and that question is
is thomas jefferson's historical legacy
and his optimistic democratic vision
substantially undercut or impaired
by reason of his insincerity
and hypocrisy
in count one of this indictment
we charge that although thomas jefferson
was a promoter of government
indeed he consistently tried to
undermine the independence
of the judiciary
and count two although thomas jefferson
was known and talked about
the great
agrarian republic
in your injury
he was a person
of personal and aggrandizement
and luxuries
and count three although thomas
jefferson often pinned about the
importance of the bill of rights
and believed in fidelity to the bill of
rights
he himself
ignored and debased that bill of
rights even up unto his death
when he decided to not free his slaves
ladies and gentlemen tonight you will
hear from
professor james chenton
a historian an expert on this most
important period
and someone who has given much thought
to the writings and the life and the
behavior of thomas jefferson
as you analyze the evidence tonight we
ask you to do so not with prejudice or
favor
or fear
but from a fair and objective
consideration of the evidence
we ask you as well to think of thomas
jefferson as he wanted to be remembered
in an idealistic aspirational way
as the chief justice has told you thomas
jefferson requested
that his tomb read as follows
here was barry thomas jefferson author
of the declaration of american
independence
of the statute of virginia for religious
freedom
and father
of the university of virginia
that epitaph says so much and so little
about thomas jefferson
it tells us a very small part of his
accomplishments
what it fails to tell us is that
jefferson a president a governor a
lawyer a professor
a prolific writer
was also someone who lived
in practice hypocrisy
it tells us that thomas jefferson who
focused on the importance of something
like the declaration of independence
would in a sense deny
the right of liberty of all
by perpetuating the injustice of slavery
for african americans
by having women treated as second-class
citizens and having native americans
treat it with even less dignity and
respect
the evidence will show that thomas
jefferson who talked about
the importance of self-governing
american young injury
an opposed urban values
had a taste for fine wines
and fine things
and he used
inspired no expense
in using both his personal assets and
the assets of his country
for its own personal benefit
the evidence will tell you that when
thomas jefferson talked about a frugal
government
he spent more
money on the louisiana purchase than he
did on that government
the evidence will tell you and professor
shenton will tell you time and again
that thomas jefferson always thought
that there was a classic choice in this
society
between
justice and self-preservation
and the evidence will undeniably suggest
to you ladies and gentlemen
that when it came to the choice between
justice
for all these this country's citizens
and justice for all of the rights
outlined in the bill of rights
and justice for the least of these in
our society
thomas jefferson was eloquent
and passionate
and clear in his writings
he was contradictory
inconsistent
hypocritical in his practices
ladies and gentlemen the jury
you will hear a lot of evidence a very
short period of time about thomas
jefferson
i implore you
to not be overwhelmed as you might be by
the greatness of this man because he was
a great man he contributed much to this
country he was important in the founding
of this country and the growth of this
country
but he as much as he espoused the purity
of our system
in eloquent terms
he also
in a sense practice hypocrisy you will
hear about the louisiana purchase
you will hear about the embargo acts
you will hear about the infamous aaron
burr trial
you will also hear more specifically
about his travels to france
and you won't have to make a judgment on
thomas jefferson just based on his
writings
but we'll ask you to judge thomas
jefferson
not on the contemporary standards
we'll ask you to judge thomas jefferson
on the qualities and the practices and
the judgments and the philosophies of
his contemporaries
his peers his equals
when we think of jesus jefferson we have
to think of george washington and
evidence will show that george
washington the father of our country a
remarkable history
at the time of his death
made sure that all of his slaves were
free
thomas jefferson failed to do as much
you will hear about alexander hamilton
and his loyalty and
to wright and thomas jefferson's
ignoring those rights
you will hear about many other important
figures in our country who made the hard
choice between rhetoric
and reality
and came down on the side of reality
i ask you as you hear this evidence to
take a dispassionate
view
i ask you to not judge him just by his
greatness but judge him by his words and
his d's
i asked you to take account of his many
accomplishments over a splendid and
illustrious career
but ultimately ladies and gentlemen the
jury i ask you to evaluate the evidence
that's before you the documents that
have been admitted and evidence and ask
you to find
that on the basis of the evidence
presented tonight
on the basis of historical fact and
reality
not based on blind admiration or
aspirational views
but based on facts that you will judge
thomas jefferson the hypocrite that we
propose
that you would find him guilty of the
three counts listed in the indictment
thank you
mr days
may it please the court mr chief justice
distinguished counsel
ladies and gentlemen of the jury
my opposing counsel and i agree on a few
things already
we agree that thomas jefferson was a
great american
that's undoubtedly true he suggested
that you as members of the jury look at
thomas jefferson's entire life
not at a compartmentalized view of what
this protean figure in american history
accomplished during his lifetime
and you're asked to
look at
the evidence
and pay close attention to it without
being
affected
by distractions
by the
high degree of evidence
and complex facts that might be
introduced at some point in the trial
this is an outrageous
proceeding
that anyone of the distinction of thomas
jefferson who is accomplished so much
for this country
should be put to public trial
in a courtroom such as this
is a tragedy for the entire country and
for all americans
it's an honor for me however to be able
to represent
thomas jefferson under these
circumstances
we will establish based upon the
evidence through our expert witness
professor joyce appleby
of ucla
that these charges are baseless
and should not be grounds for finding my
client guilty as
charged there are three counts as you've
heard
in
this particular proceeding the first has
to do with
thomas jefferson's alleged attack upon
the independence of the judiciary
the second charges him with extravagant
living
and the third raises questions about his
fidelity to the bill of rights and his
admiration and reverence for that
document
let's take the counts one at a time
as the complaint alleges
he relentlessly attacked the
independence of the federal judiciary
if one puts this charge in context
however what one sees has as
been already pointed out
is that jefferson came into office
after lame duck federalists with the
assistance of john adams
had enacted the judiciary act of 1801
vastly increasing the federal judiciary
and filling post with their partisans
it was the federalist who made a
partisan issue of the federal judiciary
and who challenged the independence
of that particular part of our
government indeed they were so bold as
to try to manipulate the structure of
the supreme court of the united states
by reducing the membership of that court
from six justices to five
which meant that had that law remained
on the books thomas jefferson would have
had to have waited for two vacancies
before he could have appointed anyone to
the court
jefferson's so-called attack upon the
independence of the judiciary was in
fact
merely an attempt to repeal
this effort by the federalists to
undermine
undermine the federal judiciary
now he could have responded in several
ways to this he could have sought an
amendment to the constitution
to undo
what the federalists had done
he could have reduced the
tenure in office
of justices of the federal judiciary but
didn't didn't do that he could also have
increased the membership of the
judiciary so that they would be able to
out vote those who had been appointed by
the federalists
it is also claimed that jefferson had a
hand in two impeachment proceedings one
against a federal district judge and the
other against the justice of the supreme
court samuel chase the evidence we are
confident will establish that thomas
jefferson was not involved in either of
these proceedings
certainly he was concerned about the
conduct of two members of the judiciary
one
an outrageous partisan who went so far
as to campaign for john adams while he
was a justice of the supreme court
delaying the opening of the term by a
few months so that he could carry out
what he saw as his responsibility in
that regard and the second judge was a
drunkard
and insane by all accounts speaking
about the views of his friends his
friends were willing to indict him
indeed impeach him perhaps on that
ground
let me turn to the second count which
has to do with this extravagant
lifestyle we're willing to concede the
thomas jefferson as a private individual
enjoyed an elegant lifestyle but that's
not the issue before this court and
before you the jury
jefferson it's important to underscore
had a categorically different view of
his public responsibilities and indeed
in office he accomplished
things that both presidents prior to
thomas jefferson and after thomas
jefferson would view as a miracle this
is a man who reduced the debt abolished
all internal taxes
invested in the future
required specific
rather than general
appropriations and reduced the executive
branch from 127 to 125 people while he
was in office and he did this
while buying louisiana and fighting the
barbary pirates
it's also alleged that he never took the
bill of rights seriously
the charge here is hypocrisy
one that we believe cannot be sustained
let's be clear what is at issue this is
not as has been suggested by my
distinguished opposing counsel not an
occasion to evaluate jefferson
an 18th century patriot by
20th century standards of political
correctness
we should also
be clear that the claim of hypocrisy
relates to a dissonance between his
words and his deeds we contend that
there was no such dissonance his views
were open and above board
some of which may be difficult for us
today
to accept our respect
and his deeds were consistent with those
views
thomas jefferson understood the
importance of the bill of rights indeed
he made clear
that
choosing between
a united states without a bill of rights
or one with a bill of rights it was
clear
that the latter was the arrangement that
otto obtained
now there are two specific charges
in the complaint one having to do with
the treatment of slavery
and the treatment of women
as a second charge
with respect to slavery
we think we will be able to show that
thomas jefferson took a consistent
position throughout his life against the
the importation of slaves and on several
occasions
not too
successful conclusion we have to
acknowledge but on several occasions
tried to ban the importation of
slaves into the united states and
finally succeeded
he also took a position on emancipation
one has to admit that it was a low
profile during the time that he was
president but he recognized on two
occasions publicly that it was a great
moral
and political evil and needed to be done
away with
jefferson had positions on the status of
slaves
and his views on the natural capacity or
incapacity of blacks would be
indefensible today
but i think we have to recognize that he
was within the mainstream of thought
during his age
we also if we're talking about the
legacy of thomas jefferson have to
recognize
that the language of the declaration of
independence pointed the way as lincoln
made clear in his springfield
illinois address
to ultimate emancipation of the slaves
in this country
with respect to women we make no bones
about the fact that thomas jefferson
viewed them as occupying a separate
sphere
this was not unusual indeed
so imminent
an american institution as the supreme
court into the late 1870s and 1880s was
using the same frame of reference for
the status of women
in summary we think ladies and gentlemen
the jury that you will find after you
hear the evidence that the charge of
tampering with the independence of the
judiciary cannot be sustained
secondly the charge with respect to
jefferson's high living is false in the
extreme
and finally
you will acknowledge based upon the
evidence that jefferson was a friend of
the bill of rights and author of the
declaration of independence a lamp that
ultimately guided this nation to
equality for groups not within its
contemplation not within jefferson's not
within washingtons
or adams
or hamilton's he was a public man who
fought to the end
to deal with
the legacy of slavery
as a private man he accepted things that
perhaps we would not accept today
but if we look at his overall
contribution we are confident that you
will find my client thomas jefferson not
guilty thank you very much
professor ogletree call your first
witness
mr chief justice at this time we'll call
professor shinton as the witness for the
prosecution
thank you right hand
you do me swear that what you say to the
court and this jury and this issue now
and trials with the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth of god
oh regardless
please be seated please state your name
for the record
james p shenton
thank you
good evening professor shinton in the
loud and clear voice could you state
your current title and where you're
employed
professor of history columbia university
ladies and gentlemen of the jury and mr
chief justice mr days and i have agreed
to stipulate to the qualifications of
each witness as an expert so the
background qualifications will be very
brief
professor stenton can you tell us
briefly your educational background i
was educated in public schools i
probably got most of the microphone
i was educated in public schools
i graduated at 17 and then got perhaps
the most profound education of my life
in three years in the army
during the second world war
came out determined to go to college
went to columbia college in 1946
graduated in 49 went on for my master's
got it in 50 and then went on for my phd
and got it in 54. okay what have you
been doing since 1954 when you got your
phd
i began teaching in 1951 and as i'm now
told at the university i am the
institutional memory
is there any backup for that
yeah
very much so can you tell us whether you
have any publications yes i have a
biography of a man named robert john
walker
i did a history of the scientific
american
i did a book on a reconstruction
i also wrote a cookbook did it sell very
well i believe if time life was telling
me the truth it was 1 million 250 000
unfortunately i accepted a fee
since those publications and general
issues about the history of our country
have you done any research or writing
or read any material on the lives and
the works of thomas jefferson uh
by the very nature of the teaching i've
done yes
uh i can't imagine teaching a course on
slavery segregation and racism
on any aspect of the history of the
american republic of the executive
office without dealing with thomas
let me ask you as well have you had the
opportunity to read any materials that
have been written by professor appleby
from the university of california los
angeles uh in fact i would recommend to
the entire audience what i think is one
of the most significant essays on the
subject
jefferson and his complex legacy
the woman is formidable
and in fact jefferson's legacy is
complex in your judgment uh most
certainly let me ask you first uh
professor shinton if you would uh to
talk to us about
thomas jefferson's view about the form
of government and more importantly and
more specifically about the independence
of the judiciary since we have limited
time i may interrupt you occasionally to
get to other questions as well to be
precise he believed that he was part of
a natural aristotle which was destined
to rule
and he was perfectly willing to allow
everyone to participate in choosing him
as long as they understood he demanded
deference
difference to him to him and what he
represented and what did he represent he
represented ultimately the proposition
that there is a privileged order who by
intellect
by birth
by place have the right to govern okay
now in fact having professor appleby
define him in other terms of someone
who's much more committed to an agrarian
society and yeomanry
i would question yeomanry but most
certainly i think that she has she views
him as more or less a forerunner of
populism
most certainly uh
a man who expresses in the most profound
way
of the significance of democracy and did
he practice democracy
depends on how you define democracy i
would say most certainly he did not
apply it to
approximately the 15 percent of the
population that was enslaved and he most
certainly did not believe that in the
context of the nature of the society he
believed in
that the masses should do anything other
than say amen
to the choices made for them
thomas jefferson has also eloquently
written about the important role of
limited government
uh and are you familiar with those
readings oh yes
uh and can you tell me whether or not
those readings those expressed views are
consistent with his actions specifically
with respect to the louisiana purchase
the embargo acts and the aaron burr
trial
show me a president
who will
spend three annual budgets without
congressional approval
to purchase louisiana
imagine mr clinton going abroad and
informing us when he gets back
he has just committed himself to spend
three trillion nine hundred billion
dollars and you get some idea what
louisiana meant
a 15 million dollar expenditure which
was the equivalent of three annual
federal budgets
i think therefore that what we have to
say is that when we deal with the
question of louisiana
it is clearly evident that this man does
not believe in limits okay
let me ask you another subject about the
idea of the embargo acts and president
jefferson of jefferson's role in that i
believe that the embargo act were the
acts of a man who recognized that he was
confronted with an international
challenge for which he had no effective
answer
now we've also had documents and they've
entered a record about thomas
jefferson's
view about the independence of the
judiciary and can you tell us
specifically about his actions both as
written and formal actions in the
context of aaron burr's trial
to begin with if you look at the concept
of the independent judiciary
most certainly if you look at his role
in the early stages of the development
of the virginia judiciary it was quite
clear that he believed in very specific
limits on the judiciary
he was not most certainly in a murder of
the idea of co-equality with the other
branches
i think that the second thing we have to
understand is that when you look at his
role
in terms of the burr trial
the bur trial was inspired in large
measure as his way of determining that
he would get even
with mr burr for what he had done back
in 1800
1801
there's a further point which i think we
should emphasize and that is that this
man believed
so emphatically upon the imperative of
destroying the judiciary act of 1801
that he participated in a deliberate
development of a case which we know as
marbury versus madison
in the expectation that the result of
that trial would
be the chief justice of the united
states would declare it being in short
an order in short that the appointment
be delivered
and he would then refuse to deliver it
john marshall was too smart to get
caught by that
john marshall in effect said the act you
were trying to use is unconstitutional
and therefore i do not have the power
when you say john marshall you're
referring to chief justice of the united
states the man who began i think the
eminence of that office
and it's carried through to this day is
that correct yes
and one of his letters a march 15 1789
letter to
james madison thomas jefferson
is quoted as saying
about the independent judiciary this is
a body which if rendered independent and
kept strictly to their own department
merits great confidence for their
learning and integrity
did he follow that creed about the
independence of the judiciary
he was i think what is typically true of
all successful political politicians a
man prepared to use pressure coercion
uh persuasion to get the right decisions
let me ask you about a letter that's
also on the record that thomas jefferson
wrote to john p epps on may 28th
in
1807 where he says quote a grand jury of
two feds four quids and ten republicans
does not seem to be a fair
representation of the state of virginia
but all this will show the original
error of establishing a judiciary
independent of the nation and which from
the sentinel of the law can turn its
guns on those they meant to defend and
control and fashion their proceedings to
its own will
is that in your judgment an indication
of jefferson's view about the judiciary
most certainly
i asked you earlier about the louisiana
purchase and the question of the
constitutionality of that act i'd like
to show you as well what's been marked
and admitted in evidence a letter dated
august 12 1803 from thomas jefferson to
john breckridge
wherein mr jefferson says talk about the
louisiana purchase
quote
the constitution has made no provision
for our holding foreign territory
still less for incorporating foreign
nations into our union
let me ask you was thomas jefferson
aware at the time of the louisiana
purchase that
was in fact unconstitutional i would
assume so he was also probably aware
there was some question of whether the
french had title
let me ask you as well moving on to
count two of the indictment thomas
jefferson has also been identified as
someone who supported agrarian reform
and opposed the urbanization of america
let me ask you specifically about thomas
jefferson's own
personal
judgments about wealth the accumulation
of wealth and how he used his resources
i always would have wanted to be invited
to monticello when he was entertaining
he knew a good bottle of wine
he knew
vintage brandy
and he was in this he was not in the
slightest inhibited by the fact that
much of what he was buying was being
bought on borrowed money
was he troubled by that
if he was he didn't make it clear
until the day of his death did he make
it clear on the day of his death yes and
what did he say
he did not say anything he just left his
slaves in a situation where they could
be liquidated to raise the money
necessary to retire his debts
uh let me ask you about
mr jefferson's view about other legal
matters he professed to support
the
individual rights can you tell me about
his views on
drafting the bill of attender
as well as his respect for the fourth
amendment at that time in the require
for warrant requirement for warrants
during the course of his governorship
during the revolution i most certainly
think there might well have been
provocation for this he did not do
anything but wink at violations of
personal safety
he most certainly was prepared to accept
bills of attainder as necessary for the
course of prosecuting any protection
that was necessary during the course of
that struggle
i think that there is an element in
jefferson in which whatever he states is
are his values they must always be
qualified by the proposition he's
opportunistic
and that if it is necessary for to
achieve a specific immediate goal
past values can be set aside
thomas jefferson is also credited with
founding the university of virginia one
of our great institutions
and he
has talked about that in fact that's
part of his epitaph
what was his views about the appointment
of professors at the university of
virginia
their tenure would be in jeopardy if
they gave forth the wrong message
and did he make that explicit yes very
explicit
uh let me ask you uh as well about the
third issue here
and that is thomas jefferson's views on
the bill of rights and the view
questions of individual liberty
thomas jefferson uh is known to
in some circles
to have some qualms about slavery in
some of his writings he has this
internal conflict that's reflected
on a number of occasions
does that reflect uh his practice as
well when it comes to slavery
there is an absolute constant in which
you can say with total certainty
jefferson never wavers
and that is emancipation must be
paralleled by expatriation
thus if you're going to free your slaves
you have to have racial cleansing
what do you mean by that you must deport
them
and that was part of thomas jefferson's
argument and precisely the reason for
that was it would be unsafe
to leave a population with such and this
is interesting such legitimate
grievances
free
to wreak vengeance
as he put it very specifically in one
scale is justice in the other is
self-preservation and self-preservation
prevails
there were some uh supporters
of the um
louisiana purchased some congressional
efforts to prevent slavery what was jeff
jefferson's view on that
again and again and again i think the
thing to bear in mind was that he saw
slavery as a necessary evil
for which there was no immediate
solution
has he put it i think this as a mere as
property a mere bagatelle
he also had the opportunity since the
district of columbia was and is under
congressional control
to abolish slavery there did he take
those steps no okay
uh he also can you tell us a little
about
the
independence of haiti in the early
1800s and president jefferson's response
in contrast to those of others
when they say a word about haiti when
haiti rebelled against the french
they staged what was most certainly a
shattering evidence of the possibility
of slave insurrections
they created from within themselves some
of the most astonishing leadership
that the the world has ever seen and
they defeated napoleon
faced with this emerging new nation
jefferson refused to allot them any
representation of a diplomatic nature
in other words a country was coming into
existence
and we did not participate in
recognizing its existence okay
you've talked about
jefferson in the general sense about
slavery let's talk specifically about
jefferson
and slavery
did jefferson own slaves and how many
he owns slaves the numbers ranged over
various
numbers during the course of his life
he may have owned that over a period of
time as many as 150. he most certainly
had to you have to
accept the fact that he drew a
significant portion of the comfort of
his life from the labor of his slaves
and was he at all in conflict or
hypocritical about that and that is that
he
openly acknowledge and have no
difficulties about slaves were were
slaves very
known to the public very openly
displayed to the public most certainly
he made no evidence to
conceal the fact he owned slaves and he
saw slavery as an institution
which was an essential prerequisite
in the society of which he was a part i
think i have to add one thing he never
called himself an american
he is a virginian
in that sense he saw his identity as
being defined
by the structure of extant values in the
state of virginia and what was the
extent values in the state of virginia
towards slavery slavery was part of the
life of that state
and as far as the governing elements of
that state was were concerned it would
remain so
in perpetuity let me ask you to
compare thomas jefferson
not to those who might judge him today
but compare thomas jefferson to some of
the more important figures of his time
on the issue of slavery for example
george washington
and alexander hamilton
i think first to understand george
washington one has to recognize that he
came from the same
state
he too was a virginian but in the course
of his developing
identity he perceived himself as an
american and understood that the
institution of slavery was a divisive
institution
as far as alexander hamilton is
concerned i don't know of anyone who had
a better fix on jefferson than he when
he had to make a decision as to whether
or not to support
jefferson or burr for the presidency in
1800
and what i'm sorry what hamilton said at
that point was simple and direct
i know the man and i know the following
if he inherits a going concern he will
not tamper with it
the other thing i think we should
understand is that hamilton was an
abolitionist
and what about others like uh john jay
benjamin franklin james otis robert
pleasants
warner mifflin can you tell me a little
bit about them all of them were
abolitionists and it seems to me that
one of the things about interpreting the
early republican period is to remember
something
the federalists collectively were the
nearest thing to an anti-slavery party
in this country
and the jeffersonian democrats were was
in effect the party of slavery
let me ask you uh
in that same vein were there people who
both
abhorred slavery and actually took the
steps of freeing their slaves at some
point
well certainly george washington did
and were there people who abhorred
slavery
and were firm and clear
by uh advocating emancipation
most certainly hamilton who was
responsible for authoring the
emancipation act of 1799 in new york
state
most certainly john jay
governor morris
the federalists in this particular
instance i think have to be recognized
as the precursor
of the political agitation against the
existence of slavery
now that
let me ask you
two final questions one
professor stinton chenton about
slaves at the time of his death
did jefferson have the opportunity
to free his slaves yes
did he
no
can you tell me what jefferson thought
about women
women were a delightful presence
one might say ornamental
i would suggest that to understand his
view of women you have to understand
that he reveled in the pleasures of
paris
in the salons
the madame de stahls
he loved
intelligent women
but women who were in effect designed
not to be intellectual equal so much as
delights and pleasures
and that that ever changed after all his
writings about liberty writings about
equality writings about our new nation
that he ever change his view before his
death
about the status of women
and not to my knowledge
uh final question
professor shinton why are you
so certain uh and so clear
about thomas jefferson's hypocrisy as
you testified today
the best answer i can give i was there
thank you very much
no further questions
[Applause]
professor shen you're subject to
cross-examination
mr days
professor shen i just want to ask you a
few questions if you will
you've talked about your
professional and educational background
and
you seem to have focused a great deal in
your testimony upon jefferson and
slavery
has this been the area of your focus
my question really is do you know
anything else about jefferson than just
his views on slavery oh yes i know about
his views of presidential power
the fact that he was essentially
ineffective
as a president in the exercise of
executive power
i think that he provided some
astonishing precedence about the scale
and scope of executive power
uh
i most certainly have delighted and
enjoyed his cars and
have delighted in reading his
correspondence and would recommend to
everyone in this audience if you really
want to understand the glory of growing
old with intelligence
read the correspondence between
alexander between thomas jefferson and
john adams
two old men
sharing their wisdom
let's test out your your understanding
of these other areas you talked about
thomas jefferson's
views of an agrarian society
and i believe you suggested that
he had
a view of himself as being an autocrat
and privileged and these other people
were below him
wasn't he concerned with
questions of commerce that is his
emphasis on the agrarian society was
consistent with his views of increasing
commerce and creating independence and
using the agrarian society is the basis
for the development of democracy
i'll preface it with a comment i did
never i hope i was i didn't convey the
idea i thought of him as autocratic
no i think he was a man who
a man who came out of a world the world
of virginia
where in large measure it was perfectly
possible to live happily and
successfully within the framework of an
agricultural society in which abundance
was the norm
and a society in which you could say
generally speaking
it provided with everyone with the basic
necessities
and most certainly he was
enthusiastically preoccupied with making
this opportunity open to everyone his
whole justification for annexation of
territory
was specifically
to make available that chance for
everyone
what was his view of of the agrarian
life and the role of the
farm community inconsistent with
concepts of democracy and participation
of the individual citizen in the
governing of the country
i would say that it wasn't as long as
you understand that he assumed something
that the choice of those people would be
those who were their betters
but they would make those decisions
freely wouldn't they there was no
suggestion that they would be coerced in
that respect what i think has to be
understood is that the mechanisms of
choice would not be theirs in the sense
of who the candidates would be
and
is that any different from what we
encountered today in our democratic
process
would presume that this is an insult to
jefferson
far too frequently today
the choice is made without any reference
to intelligence
to
capacity
what jefferson insisted on
was that those who governed to be
demonstrably qualified to govern
and that the he did also extend in his
perception of this process that the
ordinary average citizen
would have the wisdom to know who they
were that should govern them
and therefore they should render the
choice in the form of a great
amen talking about a democratic on that
aren't you
well i i i would have to i i'm in a
position where i'm going to have to
almost say to you
depends on what you mean by democracy
well are you suggesting that there's an
inconsistency between
jefferson's support for the agrarian
society
and concepts of individual rights and
participation in the governing of the
country
yes there is an inconsistency and
perhaps we have to step back to the
relationship with burr the most
objectionable thing about burr was that
he insisted
that the masses
should choose
everything from top down
in other words i think the thing to
understand about burr was what made burr
so ex
unacceptable to jefferson was that he
was the final awesome danger of the
urban masses
he created tammany
well you speak very
favorably and somewhat glowingly of
alexander hamilton i know we're in his
jurisdiction
but
uh
can you explain to the jury the
difference between jefferson's views and
hamilton's views in terms of
participation of the common people in
the governing of the country
i don't think that there was
much of a difference in terms of the
fact that both believed
that they were
members of an aristo an aristotle
who were destined to rule
i think the thing about hamilton was
that hamilton made no effort to cater
to any effort at
creating an illusion that he was a
leveler he wasn't
he was a man who believed in certain
basic values
and he pursued them with with relentless
determination
and as a result he died
professor shenton you talked about the
louisiana purchase and you're very
critical of what jefferson did i wonder
what the public response was to
jefferson's purchase of louisiana and
also
do you happen to know what the impact of
the purchase of the louisiana
territory was upon the
budget
of the united states and the debt of the
united states the immediate result was
that he had committed ourselves to
expending 15 million dollars
he admitted quite candidly it was an
opportunistic situation and he seized
him i'm not sure i would have joined him
in that
but your view shared by other people at
the time that the event actually
occurred i would say a sizable number of
people also shared in that
i think the thing that's bothersome
about jefferson is not so much the act
but his insistence upon arguing
consistently over and over again
us for strict construction of the
constitution
he presided precedent after precedent
which indicated he wasn't prepared to
subscribe by his own commitment
well you you mentioned that in
connection with the louisiana purchase
and
you referred to the
his correspondence with
senator breckenridge
he had a constitutional concern about
the purchase of louisiana but
you seem to suggest in your your answers
that he thought the purchase itself was
unconstitutional is that a correct
understanding of his views
what i think he said in a variety of
ways was what he had done
might not pass
constitutional scrutiny
most certainly the constitution is very
specific all money bills originate where
in the house of representatives but what
about the treaty power
how does the treaty power determine that
you can expend money without first
getting the approval of the house of
representatives well you can go back and
get that approval certainly can't you
ask the questions and the witness
answered
would it have been unconstitutional
under those circumstances he got the
money he must have got it from somewhere
to purchase louisiana
i think that what happened was that it
was became very clear
that the
value
the perspective of value of what he had
gotten which by the way he didn't really
understand what it was he sent lewis and
clark out to find out what it was it was
15 million dollars too much in light of
the fact that jefferson and many other
people felt that there might be war with
france it was 15 million dollars too
much to prevent the country at that
stage in its development from entering
to a war with the european power i think
i've gone through that hadn't we i think
that the real point was that he saw an
opportunity
and disregarding any constitutional
scruples he acted
on what he thought were the advantages
well correct me if you think it's wrong
but uh my understanding is that the
constitutional issue was whether states
could be created out of the louisiana
purchase that was his constitutional
concern not whether the purchase was
proper itself let me turn to to slavery
and you're very harsh on my client in
this respect
is it your position that thomas
jefferson did nothing to try to
ameliorate the situation with respect
particularly to the importation of
slaves into the united states
do you deny that there was an act of
1806 that took advantage of the
provision of the constitution to shut
off the importation of slaves as of
january first 1808
the constitution specifically stated
that the importation of slaves would
terminate in 1808
and that's right that said that congress
could not
end it
not end it
well doesn't that mean something no
president then implementation
the interpretation of slaves would be
terminated as of 1808
and what would then follow would have to
be the enabling legislation
that implemented that act i think your
mistake and professor as to the
provision of the constitution i think
that all it provided was that congress
after that time could prohibit the
importation
my time is up
thank you
at this time before we go to the defense
let's have any juror or speculator
wishes to rise and take a seventh inning
stretch do so
the prosecution rest
mr days call your first witness
i'd like to call professor joyce appleby
to the stand
raise your right hand
you do solemnly swear that what you say
to the court and jury in this issue not
on trial should be the truth the whole
truth is yourself to god
please be seated
and please state your full name for the
record
joyce appleby thank you
professor appleby
would you indicate
where you were presently employed
at the university of california in los
angeles and how long have you been in
that position since 1981.
would you describe your professional
training
yes i'm an american historian my
specialty is the 18th century and that
particularly the the revolutionary
generation
where did you receive your advanced
degrees
at claremont graduate school and the
university of california santa barbara
professor appleby you're aware that
we are gathered here today
this evening
to consider
the legacy of thomas jefferson and i
wondered whether you could indicate to
the members of the jury and to the court
what
expertise you have in that particular
regard in
jefferson his life and time
well i wrote a dissertation on the
impact of american political ideas and
constitutional theories on the french
revolution and
uh subsequently i did a study of the
jeffersonian republicans in the 1790s
and
i've written a number of articles as
well about the jeffersonian legacy and
jefferson and farming and
jefferson and his opponents
and i believe professor shenton the
expert witness for the prosecution
described an article that you had
written
that
acknowledge the complexity of thomas
jefferson's legacy do you continue to
adhere to that view i do indeed well
let's explore some of that complexity
for the jury and for the court
i'd like to focus first on the context
as i mentioned in my opening statement
that
existed when thomas jefferson became
president with respect to the judiciary
could you describe for
the jurors a little bit more about the
judiciary act of 1801 and its impact on
the judiciary well i think it's
important to realize that that jefferson
had won a very bitterly hard-fought
campaign in 1800 against the sitting
president john adams so the judiciary
act of 1801 has to be seen in relation
to that campaign because it was an act
passed by a lame duck congress and
signed into law by a lame duck president
and in it as you
noted not only was there a reduction in
the size of the supreme court uh which
meant that jefferson would not be able
to appoint uh someone to the supreme
court until two people had left it but
it also would create 16 new circuit
judges
in all
atoms in his last two months of office
appointed
some 217 office holders so what we see
here is an effort of a of a repudiated
party
uh to create a partisan enclave in the
judiciary through the judiciary act of
1801.
thank you
i'd like to turn now to the question of
the impeachment proceedings against
justice chase and against
john pickering the judge in new
hampshire
can you describe
what basis there was from an historical
standpoint or concern about
justice chase and his behavior both on
and off the bench
well
justice chase was not a temperate person
he was extraordinarily partisan and he
showed that partisanship in a number of
instances
he was a very aggressive
judge almost attempted to say prosecutor
though he was in fact a judge of the
alien incision act which was another
partisan federalist act aimed at
suppressing dissent aimed at
particularly closing
the
down the
jeffersonian newspapers so in in these
instances in one instance in particular
he
holds up a grand jury for a night urging
them to find some evidence of sedition
he's so sure there's sedition in the in
the area another time he berates a grand
jury in a very partisan way not only
attacking
the repeal of the 1801 judiciary act but
also being highly critical of a law in
the state of maryland which has just
extended the suffrage he said it's going
to bring in mobocracy and then he makes
a very uh pointed attack at the
president as a kind of a a theorist who
had does who is in support of democracy
which is going to be the undoing of the
united states
you mentioned
uh he
detained a grand jury could you be more
specific this was the delaware this is
in in wilmington i believe well
he is interested in in uh getting an
indictment against a jeffersonian
newspaper and he is quite certain that
if they
would act they could then prosecute this
jeffersonian paper and the grand jury
does not find forty he refuses to
release them and they spend the night uh
locked up as they were and then spoiled
he finally lets him go
now there's been
an assertion
from time to time that jefferson had a
hand in
setting
in motion the impeachment of justice
chase could you address that particular
charge against thomas jefferson well
it's based on one very skimpy bit of
evidence i think
chase's very high-handed partisan
lecturing of the baltimore grand jury
elicited a critical article from
a
witness to it in baltimore and this
article was sent to jefferson jefferson
passed it on to a member of congress
joseph hopper
nicholson and uh refers to this as
something that perhaps the the
congress would want to look into
that's where the matter drops as far as
jefferson's concerned and nicholson
himself never does anything about it the
impeachment of chase is taken up by
jefferson's
enemy john randolph and it is prosecuted
by randolph largely in opposition to
jefferson who is pursuing a much more
moderate course
vis-a-vis this partisan
federal judiciary well just to just be
clear about this randolph and jefferson
were not opponents
all the time were there well well
randolph was nominally in the
jeffersonian camp but he had been
increasingly unhappy with jefferson in
part because jefferson had not tried to
um
get rid of all the federalists who were
entrenched in judicial positions he
would like to have had jefferson fire
them all
and jefferson
with respect to jefferson's position on
the chase impeachment you recall in the
letter you're referring to he said
office seditious and official act on the
principles of our constitution on the
proceedings of the state to go
unpunished
did he ever express any regret of having
said that or ever any public retreat
from that position no he never said
writes anything else about it this is a
private letter and he also refers to the
fact that this matter should be
constitutionally it was congress that
should pursue this so he clearly sees
it's not the rule the president to do
anything other than to pass on this
article which has been sent to him
it was also an assertion that he had a
hand in the impeachment of john
pickering
to the effect that
he stirred up congress to
initiate impeachment proceedings against
sean's pickering and provided the
congress with all kinds of documentation
that got the proceeding underway what's
your view of
those allegations well there are a good
many rather horrifying stories about
pickering and
jefferson does
pass these on in a very uh temperate way
saying that he is laying before
uh congress which he feels is his duty
to do
leaving to them to act as they see fit
turning to the the claim of
luxurious living
on the part of thomas jefferson
could you say something about the way
that jefferson comported himself as
president of the united states in terms
of
his living arrangements and his
entertaining and the way he handled his
account
yes i think it's very interesting that
this charge should be laid at his door
because one of the things that he does
when he becomes president is stop having
these elaborate and very formal levies
that george washington and john adams
had had and instead institutes a policy
of very informal entertainment at the
white house he sees very uh much the
political significance of the
president's accessibility and instead of
only appearing to voters uh in in on a
raised diocese as as washington did at
his levees he actually answers the door
himself he introduces a a
an etiquette for diplomatic dinners in
which the principal of pell mel uh
supersedes that a protocol as to say he
who is next to the door goes in first
this is highly offensive to the
ministers from spain and france and
england he's extraordinarily informal
and because he
truly believes
that this kind of awe that is engendered
by formality is what keeps a democracy
from
being a vibrant lived experience how was
the entertainment that
he conducted paid for professor appleby
well i think it was paid for by his
salary the president of the united
states had a very handsome salary that's
true of all the presidents so he was not
drawing from the federal treasury in the
sense of paying for this these expenses
that came out of his pocket so to speak
no in fact he was very frugal he was
given five thousand dollars to to uh
furnish the white house it had not yet
been furnished by the time he became
president and he was much more concerned
about fixing the potholes in
pennsylvania avenue and so he committed
3000 of that to repairing pennsylvania
avenue and planting 200 lombard trees
a very public spirited gesture i think
anyone who's lived and driven on
pennsylvania avenue lived in washington
driven on it could appreciate
i this charge seems to be very strange
because it's very opposite of the way in
which he conducted
the entertainment
he had two two receptions uh two annual
receptions which everyone was invited
one was on the fourth of july and the
other was new year's day but again he
was trying to reach out to the people
and to make them to make the president
uh accessible to them and to make them
feel that they are indeed part of this
new society now you've heard the charge
that thomas jefferson
talked and wrote a lot about
limited government but actually didn't
practice limited government did you
address those those charges
well i think he had a remarkable record
of making promises and living up to them
he wanted a limited government he indeed
cut the size of the bureaucracy as you
have heard even though the population
had grown during his eight years and he
had doubled the geographic area uh in at
the end of his first term it began with
he
promised to get rid of internal taxes
and internal taxes are eliminated he
promised to
retire the debt as quickly as possible
at the end of his first term he has a
million dollar surplus and he has done
this while purchasing louisiana and this
includes paying the interest on the
stock for the purchase of louisiana
so i think that he was frugal
i think that's
obviously a very difficult thing for a
president to do i think it's astounding
that he would reduce the size of the
patronage at a time in his party he was
very unhappy because the federalists had
taken up most of the patronage in their
midnight appointments he also cut the
military budget in half
he moved the land offices out into the
west where ordinary people would have
access to them instead of pursuing the
federalist policy of selling large
tracts of land to speculators in
philadelphia or new york interesting
land sales were
something around
67 000 in 1800 and
the first year of his presidency the
land sales moved to 500 000 acres a year
and stayed there so his policy of
delivering to the people that which they
most wanted uh was carried out i think
jonah may i assure the witness an
exhibit
i'd like to show you uh professor
appleby
exhibit a
which i'd like you to identify and if
you could place that letter in
context with respect to this charge of
i believe he has counsel do you have a
copy
well uh this is a letter that jefferson
writes to eldridge gary in which he it's
in the middle of the campaign 1799 and
gary is sort of has obviously retailed
to jefferson a lot of the charges that
have been made against him in new
england and jefferson is setting forth
there what he uh believes
his presidency will stand for and indeed
i think it's a very fair summation he
talks about his his uh
commitment to the con to the
constitution
uh to his desire to have limited
government his respect to the division
of power powers his uh interest in in uh
reducing the size of the civil service
and and of cutting the military
appropriations depending as he says
solely on the militia all of these are
in fact things that jefferson did do in
office well if we were looking at that
letter in modern
political
circumstances what would you call a
letter like that
well i don't know i would say that it
was an extraordinarily honest letter
from an extraordinarily honest man well
parties usually have statements uh that
they put forward about what they're
going to do oh you mean a campaign
promise i suppose yes i think what's
interesting is that that he's so clear
uh in reference to the sort of the uh
the jupiter of attacks that have been
made upon him and that we have his
record as president to show that these
are not merely words um this may be a
campaign platform but unlike most
platforms he stood on it
thank you
i'd like to turn to the
third
charge against
thomas jefferson having to do with his
view of the bill of rights
and his record with respect to
freedom of the press
freedom of religion
and the treatment of slaves and and
women
since so much time has been devoted by
the prosecution to the issue of slavery
i'd like you to
address
thomas jefferson's views on
first
the importation question i attempted
through
questions on cross-examination to elicit
some of these points from
the expert for the prosecution but i i
think it would help the jury to hear
perhaps more concise and precise
statements with respect to that
particular issue well i think it's
important to see that that
internationally in in terms of a nascent
of beginning anti-slavery movement um in
the late 18th century there were really
two issues one was abolishing the slave
trade so that there would be no increase
in the number of
african men and women stolen and and
sold into slavery and the other was to
get rid of the institution itself
uh and the first i think jefferson's
record is very good um he was certainly
a part of virginia house of bridges that
would like to have
have uh embarrassed the the sale of
slaves in virginia uh during the
colonial period and and they were
frustrated in doing that he also um had
proposed an elimination he also as as
you described um made sure
that at the first at the earliest
opportunity when the slave trade could
be abolished which was not until 1808
because the constitution had prevented
any legislation on the slave trade it
had said nothing about
ending it it merely prevented the end of
it for 20 years and jefferson makes sure
that a bill has passed congress and is
on his desk ready for signature at the
earliest opportunity so i don't think
there's much of a
a doubt about where he stood on that
would you like me to go on and talk
about slavery
the charge here is one of hypocrisy
now you've talked about his position on
the importation of slaves
what about emancipation itself and
if you could go beyond discussion of
emancipation to a discussion of his
views of
the
nature of the negro as he called it or
the black slave
from his standpoint and the extent to
which his position
reflected hypocrisy which is as i said
the charge right
well certainly he saw it as a very vexed
issue and he was certainly aware of the
contradictions between slavery and
natural rights philosophy
it's hard to understand how he could be
charged with hypocrisy because he shared
most of these opinions with his
contemporaries and in his one book notes
on the state of virginia it is there
that he uh describes his
the suggestion he says of negro
inferiority this is published book this
is something that he is exploring as a
possibility but even more moving in that
book is his description of what slavery
does to both master and slave the
boisterous passions that is done that in
unleashes as he says the most degrading
submission in the one and the most
overpowering arrogance in the other and
he talks about this that the slavery is
an institution that teaches
um both whites and blacks roles that are
profoundly undermining of human dignity
now this is a
a man who is as it were bearing his soul
in this book so it's hard to see the
they say the charge of hypocrisy as far
as slavery is concerned i i don't
believe he could see his way through to
the emancipation of slavery in virginia
given the attitudes of his fellow
planters but he does see the possibility
of halting the spread of slavery and in
the
uh he proposes when he's a member of the
continental congress that none of the
land that has been acquired in the
treaty of paris the land between the
appalachians and the and the mississippi
but none of that land should have uh
slaves brought on to it and that
proposal is defeated by one vote which
very chastens and and crestfallen
jefferson comments about where was god
in his heaven when that boat was cast
but this idea does bear fruit
in the or northwest ordinance of 1787
jefferson is then in paris when this is
passed but in it as you know ladies and
gentlemen of the jury the extension of
slavery is blocked in the northwest in
the five states to become that that was
jefferson's idea and he planted it there
the prosecution has
attempted
to persuade the jury that
jefferson was in some fashion out of
step with his colleagues and his peers
on questions of slavery and i'd like to
explore that with you for a moment i
think the prosecution has conceded that
george washington
had slaves
at the same time the thomas jefferson
had slaves
he did free them
in his will but of course this was after
he was dead and had no
direct impact on him by definition
what about madison did he have slaves
yes madison had slaves
uh this is the person who drafted the
bill of rights yes
and what about
that distinguished jurist john marshall
did he have marshall had slaves
well there's a reference to the
federalists being an anti-slavery party
and a mention of john jay and governor
morris and
alexander hamilton
uh is that a correct characterization of
of the federalist party
well i don't know that's the correct
characterization but i think all credit
should be given to those men for for
being
against slavery and for leading the way
for the emancipation of slavery in their
states however it should be pointed out
that they were all northerners as
jefferson said slavery has been entailed
upon us and i think that that was an
adequate metaphor for his
recognizing that here was a population
of virginia in which forty percent of
the uh was uh enslaved that's not the
case in
new york new jersey rhode island
massachusetts they're the the uh slave
population or free and slave population
would be in the neighborhood of four to
eight percent
uh but i do think all credit should be
given
to hamilton and jay
uh and governor morris for their
leadership in this issue
okay
thank you very much professor apple
please remain uh seated for the
cross-examination
good apple good evening uh you know i'm
charles oakley through the prosper in
this case i do understand that people in
this country let me ask you one general
question uh your
statement is that thomas jefferson
quote was in good company
in owning slaves because others own
slaves as well some of our most notable
uh heroes is that correct i don't think
i said he was in good company was he in
good company
well i would like to think that he was
in good company because these men uh
founded the constitution and were
led the revolution not because they were
fellow slave owners in fact they were
hypocritical weren't they they talked
about liberty but they supported
and exploited slavery is that correct i
don't think they were hypocrites they
talked about the extension of liberty
and that they accomplished did they give
liberty to slaves no jefferson ever give
liberty to the nearly 200 slaves that he
owned
but he gave liberty to five of them five
out of 200 that's pretty good isn't it
let me ask you professor appleby there
is uh
one authoritative article that talks
about jefferson in contrast to many of
our other important
historical figures and ask you whether
you share
this statement as being accurate
jefferson was not
george washington's equal as an
administrator
do you agree with that no you disagree
with that yes
and jefferson was not hamilton's equal
as a political economist do you agree
with that i agree with that
uh and jefferson uh was not madison's
equal as a systemic
systematic political philosophy i agree
with that
uh in fact jefferson fell short in
comparison to
hamilton and madison on the points i
just mentioned that correct
yes he was not an economic theorist and
he wasn't a political theorist let's
talk about the independence of the
judiciary one of the first charges that
we've brought
and you talked about thomas jefferson's
role
in the
prosecution of justice chase
right
i answered questions about uh
justice but you talked about it is that
right
but not his prosecution
uh
isn't it
and you talked about
justice justice chase's views about the
grand jury and his criticism of grand
jury right
in fact uh would you characterize him as
an interpret
jurist
his contemporaries so characterized him
would you characterize him as an
intemperate jurist
i suppose so
and was he alone
in the judiciary and being intemperate
oh not at all but he was not uh he was
alone in being the subject of an
impeachment is that correct
there were two impeachments but as far
as the national federal judiciary yes
and you also talked about
mr jefferson's in a sense living within
his means
that he was a frugal man in terms of the
way he ran government and the way he ran
his personal life well he was certainly
frugal as far as his public life as far
as what he did with the people's money
yes
well there was a contradiction in terms
of what he espoused in his public life
and what he practiced in his private
life i don't think so
was he extravagant in his expenditures
i don't think so
do you know
based on the historical record
yes i would say so did he purchase
expensive wines from places like france
we purchased wine yes was it expensive
wine
i haven't seen a price list i don't know
let me ask you this would it be
character wise that he was
has never been characterized that he was
someone who purchased cheap wine
no
or at least never bad wine
did he also have
portraits of important people that were
of great value then and now
well he certainly had uh engravings of
people he had busts of people he had a
house that he filled with furniture yes
uh and he also
uh was in some sense that you talked
about his informal i mean wasn't he also
a man uh of great
luxury in terms of the way things were
run uh the design of monticello
i don't think so it's full of
convenience and the time-saving devices
and silent butlers and the likes the
time-saving devices included a couple
hundred slaves right
i was thinking of how he was trying to
save their time with the asylum butlers
he was trying to save their time he
could have saved their time by freeing
them that's one way right
he didn't choose to do that is that
correct no and he was a supporter have
one question at a time
[Music]
let me talk specifically about
the bill of rights one of thomas
jefferson's
uh most important areas of commentary he
was a believer in the bill of rights
wasn't it
he was certainly a believe believer yes
in belgium yes
criticized i'm
did you say he criticized the
constitution in a letter to madison for
the absence of a bill of rights he
wanted a bill of rights yes he supported
trial by jury
and supported the rights of minorities
right i don't know about that well did
you ever read uh his first inaugural
where he talked about
equal and exact justice
to all men
so he supported equality is that correct
yes but that did not apply
to slaves is that correct that's right
it didn't apply to women no is that
correct it didn't apply to native
americans well it would have there would
have been some who would have been
citizens yes
well it wouldn't apply to native
americans who weren't in the within the
boundaries of the united states which
most of them are not i'd like to come
back in a moment to the question
of slavery but i want to ask you about
a free press
in your view the jefferson consistently
support free press
well certainly he supported a free press
within the um
limitations of the common law and
seditious libel
did he support
free press as it was written upon
freedom of the press
right and did he ever contradict
the law
by supporting limitations
on freedom of speech
you're talking now before the
constitution the state of virginia and
he was prosecuting the war
i
i
can't say categorically but i i would
certainly believe it'd be possible when
he was wartime governor that he might
have tolerated infringements of freedom
of press didn't he tolerate restrictions
on military speech
i can imagine that yeah he tolerated
seditious libel prosecutions well he
certainly would have tolerated those
because he believed that there was a
loss that is just liable but he believed
the state should exercise it not the
federal government and he also supported
political attacks on the press is that
correct i don't believe so
uh he also let me ask you specifically
about the issue of slavery
can you tell us a word about albert
gallatin and his role in our federal
government yes albert gallatin was
jefferson's secretary of the treasury
and in his capacity as secretary of the
treasury that he at one time proposed
to president jefferson
that it would be helpful
because of the short supply of
first-rate talent
in government
that he should use
slaves
or women
women yes
and gallatin thought it was a good idea
to use women as equals because of their
talent in our government is that correct
he said he proposed to jefferson that
perhaps since they were having trouble
filling positions they might choose some
women and what was jefferson's reply can
you quote his reply i think with
something like the the public this is an
innovation that the public is not ready
for nor am i okay let me ask you if i
could um
if you want to quote more specifically
i'd like to show you what uh
jefferson's legacy can you quote the
actual language of president jefferson
about the role of women in government
during his presidency
well his response to galatan is the
appointment of a woman to office is an
innovation for which the public is not
prepared nor am i
and there's a line that follows that it
says quote women as he explains that
several correspondents
were formed by nature for men's need and
pleasure yes
and can you tell me who wrote that line
and the book that i just shown you
yes i did
and that in fact was true is that
correct
jefferson certainly expressed that
opinion about women publicly
often
jefferson also
uh in his notes on the state of virginia
talked about the inferiority of
african-americans that correct yes
his suspicion and he also talked about
the cultural differences between
whites and native americans that correct
yes
and
as a moral matter
did jefferson abhor slavery
yes
in fact though to his death he retained
his slave is that correct
yes
no further questions
very well you may step down professor
appleby
[Applause]
does the defense rest mr days very well
we'll have closing arguments professor
ogletree
okay
we regarded your honor as quasi-criminal
ladies and gentlemen of the jury
you've heard the evidence you've heard
the
argument of counsel
when we began these proceedings
i indicated that the prosecution
and the defense both agreed that thomas
jefferson was a great american
we also agreed that we would not judge
thomas jefferson by
20th century standards
what the prosecution has attempted to do
is
depart from its own
admission
at the beginning of these proceedings
by trying to undermine
the legacy of this great american we
think the evidence demonstrates that
thomas jefferson did not attempt to
undermine the independence of the
judiciary he was in fact responding to
efforts by
the opposite side to politicize
and damage the federal judiciary in a
way that would have been felt down to
this present day if it had succeeded
fully and without his intervention
there is no evidence the prosecution has
not been able to summon one shred of
evidence that thomas jefferson was
involved in the impeachment proceedings
against justice chase or john pickering
there simply is no evidence for that
proposition
with respect to
his luxurious lifestyle i mentioned at
the beginning and i knew that this was
going to happen the prosecution was
going to try to confuse in your mind
what thomas jefferson did on his own
time with his own money and what he did
with the public's money what he did with
the tax dollars
of your forebears
that distinction is important to keep in
mind you should not be confused by what
the prosecution has attempted to do
thomas jefferson was
a president who promised limited
government
and delivered on limited government in a
way that i think all of you would agree
would be wonderful to see in modern
times although it's probably unlikely
this is a man who reduced the debt who
expanded the country as i've indicated
and as the evidence has demonstrated
it was nothing short of a miracle for
him to do do so under those
circumstances
and with respect to the bill of rights
the prosecution has attempted to apply
modern day standards
but it's failed
because as the evidence makes clear
thomas jefferson
was opposed to slavery attempted to do
what he could within his powers to end
the importation of slavery
and to the extent that there were others
of his peers
who were opposed to slavery and did not
hold slaves they were northerners they
lived in communities where slavery was
outlawed they presented
uh no challenge to thomas jefferson from
a moral standpoint because they had no
dilemma it was easy for them to act as
they did because it was consistent with
the law
i ask you to consider what thomas
jefferson faced with the more he's faced
with the history faced with the
political pressures of virginia had to
do
in order to speak out as he did
against the importation of slavery and
to express the moral evil of slavery
across the board
this was not an easy thing to do and it
demonstrates the courage of thomas
jefferson that we have seen
throughout his public and private life
no he didn't free his slaves
but we know that washington had slaves
and he was big enough to free them when
he died
we know that madison had slaves we know
that marshall had slaves this is not to
condone the owning of slaves it is not
to
exonerate or excuse thomas jefferson for
what he was doing
it's simply to
emphasize the point
that he was not out of the mainstream
that he was struggling with the same
issues that many americans were
struggling with indeed continued to
struggle with up through the
emancipation proclamation indeed
struggle with to this very day when we
deal with questions of race and race
relations
so
judging thomas jefferson by modern
standards
perhaps
is not such a bad idea to a limited
extent we are still as a country
struggling with these issues and
very few of us
have been willing to show the courage of
thomas jefferson in admitting one's
position and living with the
consequences
in summary what we have is
one of the shining lights of this
republic
a person
whose work
and writings
and actions
move this country in the direction
of liberty and freedom of equality for
people
who without
the language of the declaration of
independence without the other writings
of thomas jefferson would perhaps not
enjoy what we enjoy today
they've been suggestions in the
prosecution's cross-examination
of my expert witness that thomas
jefferson
was interested in
suppressing free speech nothing could be
more contrary to what thomas jefferson
actually did
in fact there's a great story of a
german
aristocrat visiting the white house and
seeing a newspaper that contained a
scurrilous attack on thomas jefferson
the aristocrat was
scandalized and thomas jefferson said
read that article take that paper with
you take it back to germany tell them
that you found it in the white house
because i want you to know what my
country stands for that we're willing as
public officials to accept that type of
criticism there have been suggestions
that he was an anti-cleric that he was
opposed to
freedom of religion but thomas jefferson
was not opposed to freedom of religion
he was not anti-clerical he was not
against religion he simply wanted his
fellow citizens
and wanted for himself the ability to
follow religious convictions where they
led
and not be
trammeled by
laws that required contributions
to establish religion
there was talk about his founding of the
university of virginia
one of the things that thomas jefferson
did in founding university of virginia
was to oppose
the creation of a chair of divinity or
religion
why did he do that because he felt that
all religions should find a home in the
university of virginia and to create a
chair of divinity or religion would
suggest that there was one right answer
to religious questions that
troubled his colleagues and continue to
trouble people unto this very day
these three charges against thomas
jefferson have to be viewed
as a whole
not bit by bit we cannot in fairness
compartmentalize the life of a person
such as thomas jefferson the threads run
through his life and they weave a very
strong
and powerful fabric of democracy
of equality
of tolerance for religious liberty for
freedom of the press
and for democracy for all americans
i urge you i implore you to find my
client
not guilty with respect to these charges
thank you very much
[Applause]
mr ogletree
may please the court
counsel voting counsel
days ladies and gentlemen of the jury
we have come to one of the most critical
and
painful moments
in our nation's history
thomas jefferson the great
philosopher
the great statesman the great patriot
the defender
of liberty at all costs
supporting limited government
and the rights of the people
will always be remembered for that
glaring light his greatness
i implore you as you weigh the evidence
in this case
to not be blinded
by that glaring light
because the picture that mr days has
pointed has painted is so eloquent
and so cheerful and so clear and bright
but it obscures the troubling and
disappointing
and hypocritical
record of thomas jefferson
throughout his life
it is a history ladies and gentlemen
this jury that we all
lament
because of his greatness
and yet even as mr day's own witness
told you
thomas jefferson who talked about
liberty
and equality
in the pursuit of happiness
was not prepared even at the suggesting
of his secretary of the treasury
to consider
the appointment
of a woman
this is a hypocrisy that's borne out in
thomas jefferson's
abhorrence of slavery as mr day's
witness
so eloquently stated
and yet throughout his life and through
his death
he never once
gave
98
of his slaves
the very precious and cherished
rights of freedom
that's so important
to our concept of liberty
and justice
it is a hypocrisy that thomas jefferson
will talk about the independence of the
judiciary
and his public words and private actions
in seeking the prosecution of
aaron burr
contradicted clearly and consistently
it is hypocrisy of the highest form
mr days and his witness will say that
mr jefferson was frugal in government
in his expenditures but admit without
objection
that he expended money on expensive
wines
and
portraits and other life necessities
it is hypocrisy ladies and gentlemen as
we judge thomas jefferson today
that was the darker side
of course we are to judge him by the
standards the time in which he lived
and yet our contemporary experience is
important we can't enter this room
without our common sense and our sense
of judgment
the chief justice will give you some
instructions in this case and ask you to
follow those instructions
how can we in light of our own history
and our present day circumstances
say that a president who may be a very
profound and important public figure
can have such a darker side in his
private life
if it's not right for william jefferson
clinton it's not right for thomas
jefferson
how can we talk about slavery
and try to excuse thomas jefferson
because
as my brother argues he's different from
his contemporaries when great men of
distinction
like john jay
alexander hamilton
benjamin franklin
james oldest
robert pleasant
warner mifflin and george washington and
jorge's wife
one of jefferson's teachers in virginia
all were unequivocal and uniformly
opposed
to slavery
and advocated for emancipation
thomas jefferson was a man who loved
liberty
his own
thomas jefferson was a man who believed
in the pursuit of happiness
his
own thomas jefferson
has to be judged
by his times and his acts
as the author of the declaration of
independence the most important and
noble document of our times
as a leader during the period of
american enlightenment
the test for thomas jefferson i submit
to you
is not ladies and gentlemen
whether he was better than the worst
of his generation
the test we submit
is whether he was the leader
of the best
the test is not whether given the times
and circumstances he responded as a
southerner
and a planner and a former
but whether he was able to transcend his
own personal
and selfish economic interest
in his sectional background
to implement the very ideas that he
epitomized and articulated
we submit to you ladies and gentlemen
based on the evidence that you heard
today
that thomas jefferson
fails that test
miserably
i implore you that as you
hear
chief justice's instructions
and as you raise your hand to find him
guilty
of all three counts
you do so as i would with a heavy heart
it is not an easy indictment
of the drafter of the declaration of
independence
it is not an easy indictment of our
third president
it is not an easy indictment of one of
the most prolific and perhaps the most
prolific man of his time
is not an easy indictment as we think
about mount rushmore
and monticello
but the next time you visit these
places the next time you see the
postcard
the next time you imagine the glory and
the glamour
we have to weigh as well the tarnish
we have to wear
observe the
reality judge thomas jefferson not
as an ideologue
not as a god
not as a king not as a principal as a
man
as the man born of his times and of his
conditions as a man of great eloquence
clarity and compassion
and judgment
and as a man
regrettably but painfully
who practiced hypocrisy
i urge you to find in your hearts
to put aside the greatness that you've
seen in thomas jefferson the greatness
that you've read
and to judge him
as history has judged it he is not an
alexander hamilton
he is not a george washington
he is not a james madison
we know that because those words were
eloquently written written by one of the
most significant and prolific jurist of
our times
who happens to be presiding tonight
and if you have any doubt whatsoever
we simply ask you to think about this
as great as he was as much as he
accomplished
thomas jefferson nevertheless would ask
you
as citizens of the world
to judge him
on the basis of principles of fairness
equality
and to judge him on the basis of all of
his records
and to judge him painfully regrettably
but most certainly
guilty as charged
and finally the chief justice will tell
you you don't have to find him guilty of
all three counts we think there's
substantial evidence
well beyond our burden of guilt on all
three counts
you simply by weighing all the evidence
and listening to the court's
instructions
ken determined that he was guilty
of hypocrisy
i urge you to reach that verdict
tomorrow we can go about improving the
record
tomorrow we can go about clarifying
tomorrow we can go about
explaining but tonight on the basis of
this record
it is time
to do your duty the citizens of this
world
and that duty is to find thomas
jefferson
guilty
as charged
thank you
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen of the jury you
have now heard the evidence and the
arguments of counsel for both
prosecution and the defense
and at the conclusion of these
instructions you will return a verdict
simply by a show of hands without the
usual collegial deliberations that
accompany
and the form of that verdict i will now
read to you because you should bear it
in mind as you hear the instruction
is thomas jefferson's legacy his
optimistic and democratic faith and
freedom
substantially impaired or undercut
by reason of his inconsistencies or
hypocrisy and so the the question will
be asked we'll ask for a show of hands
yes and a show of hands no
uh
nothing i say in these instructions is
to be taken as an indication that i have
any opinion about the facts of the case
or what that opinion is it is not my
function to determine the facts but
rather yours
you must perform your duties as jurors
without bias or prejudices to any party
the law does not permit you to be
governed by sympathy prejudice or public
opinion
all parties expect that you will
carefully and impartially consider all
the evidence follow the laws it is now
being given you and reach a just verdict
the issue for your resolution tonight is
whether thomas jefferson's legacy his
democratic faith and individual liberty
is substantially impaired or undercut by
reason of hypocrisy that is
inconsistency between his words and his
deeds
mr ogletree the prosecutor in this case
has charged jefferson with hypocrisy in
three broad areas
his view regarding the independence of
the judiciary
his praise of frugality and agrarian
values and his extolling of individual
liberty
mr days representing thomas jefferson
denies these charges
please note that you are to take as a
given the fact that thomas jefferson has
left a legacy of democratic faith and
individual liberty
the questions you must decide this
evening break down into two
to what extent are the charges of
hypocrisy against jefferson made out by
the evidence you've heard
and if you find that various parts of
the charges of hypocrisy are indeed made
out does this conclusion substantially
impair or undercut the legacy of thomas
jefferson
you should first consider the factual
accusations of hypocrisy made against
jefferson and the complaint to which
i've referred
you must decide whether on the basis of
the evidence
whether and to what extent these charges
are true
if you find that they are false or true
only in insignificant detail
you need go no further and should return
a verdict that finds jefferson not
guilty in effect answer the question
that you're asked no
if you conclude that the charges of
hypocrisy are made out with respect to
any of the three areas charged in the
complaint judicial independence
brutality and
agrarian values and individual liberty
you must then go on and consider whether
the truth of those charges that you find
to be true substantially undercuts or
impairs the jeffersonian legacy
this is more of a judgment call than the
more factual question of whether
jefferson was hypocritical to decide the
second question you must evaluate the
jeffersonian legacy and decide whether
it is the sort of legacy that is
undercut by a proven charge of hypocrisy
to elaborate briefly if we take two of
the four representatives of the allied
powers of the versailles peace
conference in 1919 following the end of
world war one
namely lloyd george the president of the
prime minister of great britain woodrow
wilson president united states
reasonable people i believe would reach
quite different conclusions with respect
to one than they would with respect to
the other as to whether proof of
hypocrisy undermined their respective
legacy lord george is regarded by
history as an opportunistic rather
unprincipled deal maker
and a proven charge of hypocrisy would
do little or nothing to undercut this
legacy
but woodrow wilson is regarded by
history as a high-minded if largely
unsuccessful idealist
and a proven charge of hypocrisy would
do a great deal to undercut that legacy
you must evaluate the jeffersonian
legacy and the effect upon it of proven
charges of hypocrisy if you so find in
this man
the prosecution represented by mr
ogletree has the burden of proving this
case oddly enough by a preponderance of
the evidence
since he has styled it a criminal case
but nonetheless he has the duty only
approving by a preponderance of the
evidence not beyond a reasonable doubt
to establish something by a
preponderance of the evidence means to
show that it is more likely than not
you must bear in mind in your
deliberations that the charge against
jefferson is hypocrisy
saying one thing and doing another and
not political incorrectness you must
judge him in evaluating these charges
not by the standards of the present day
but by the standards which he himself
espoused
judged with the benefit of hindsight
jefferson's vision of a future america
was wrong in more than one way
but again the charge against him is not
lack of farsightedness but of hypocrisy
uh i will now pose the question to you
and give you about uh two minutes to
simply think about it because i'm sure
we want a little deliberative uh
activity on on on the part of the jury
and at the end of the
uh
two minutes i'll ask for a show of hands
first yes and then a show of hands no
and with the assistance of the clerk uh
we will we will uh the clerk will uh mr
fletcher will count the hand showing on
the
on my left in the audience i will count
the hand showing on my right in the
audience
very well the question is
is thomas jefferson's legacy
his optimistic and democratic faith and
freedom
substantially impaired or undercut by
reason of his inconsistencies or
hypocrisy
let me read the question once more and
then i'll call for a hands on a show of
hands of the yes vote
is thomas jefferson's legacy his
optimistic and democratic faith and
freedom substantially impaired or
undercut by reason of his
inconsistencies or hypocrisy
all those who answer yes raise your
hands
17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25 26.7 28
29.
how many did you get mr clerk
i get 29 you get 48 that means
77 say yes
all those who say no in answer to the
question raise your hands
one two three four five
i think we can say that the verdict
i think we can say the verdict is
returned
uh by a substantial majority that the
answer to the question of whether
jefferson's legacy
is impaired by inconsistency or
hypocrisy is answered in the negative
let me thank all the participants
[Applause]
and the court stands reese adjourned
cena d.a
[Applause]
[Applause]
you did a great job
[Music]
this mock trial of thomas jefferson was
organized by the new york city bar
association's continuing education
committee the event explored alleged
inconsistencies between jefferson's
ideas and actions
monday evening on c-span a live call-in
program previewing the confirmation
hearing for supreme court nominee judge
stephen breyer
the senate judiciary committee begins
consideration of judge breyer's
nomination tuesday morning
the preview call-in will originate from
the hearing room in the heart senate
office building
monday at 6 30 pm eastern time 3 30
pacific
this week